القصه الابرز والمثيره للجدل خلال الايام
الماضيه في المونديال والتي شغلات الصحف
العالميه مواقع التواصل هي واقعه رئيس
اتحاد الكاميروني لكره القدم سامويل ايتو
الموسم باسطوره كره القدم وهو يهاجم شابا
جزائريا خارج ملعب في كاس العالم في قطر
المقطع الذي نشاته صحيفه لوبينيون بدا فيه
ايتو سعيدا بالتقاط الصور مع المشجعين
المنتظرين قبل ان يقترب منه الرجل يحمل
كاميرا فيديو ثم تظهر وتظهر لقطات ما يدور
حوارا بين الرجلين قبل ان ينقطع الفيديو
يتوانا ويعود الى مكان الحادث لمواجهه
الرجل والهجوم بشرى عليه وركله في وجهه
وفشل 4 رجال
[موسيقى]
اول شيء الحدث النفس من الناس شافته تعرض
عيطوا علي بالضرب هذاك الضرب الي انا اصلا
قلت لهم ما كنت اعتقد ان هذا الشيء يحدث
طالع من ارضيه الميدان يعني اصور فيديوهات
عاديه مثل ما اني اصور حياتي اليوميه حتى
شفتو متجمعين عليه ناس ياخذون معاها
يلتقطوه معاه صور قلت انا كوني انا
يوتيوبر خليني اسمع الحدث يعني بطريقه
خاصه اني اتكلم فيديو واسال عادي يعني
السؤال رياضي واللي زايد الطين
انا جزائري ممكن لم يفهم حديثي باللغه
الانجليزيه
كانت الناس تاخذ معها صور قلت لها هيك صور
عادي هو راح يمشي وانا مشيت معه اهم
على القنوات وال صار في كل مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في قطعه وهذه القطعه فيها لغز
وقبل ما يضربني مسكني من شعري يعني مسكني
قال لي انت غبي قال لي انت غبي انت غبي
راح قلت لها قلت لها تعلم انا لماذا غبي
لاني انا جزائري
سمع منك له زوجه الجزائريه
راح اسالك سؤال في ما يخص المباراه على
الجزائر
الكاميرا على حساب الجزائر
لم يتم الرد على الجزائر
عليك هو تهاجم علي الديك الوحشيه للناس
كلها للاسف الشديد لم اتوقع يتصاموال اللي
كنت انا من عشاق برشلونه يوم من ايام احب
هذا اللاعب اتمنى التقط معه صوره اليوم
يضربني اعتقد لم اتوقعها لاعب كبير مثل
اذا صامول لازم تقبل انتقاله حتى لو انا
انتقدتك نصاري انا لم انتقده والله لم
انتقد يعني الناس حللت الناس شافت قالت
مستحيل انه رئيس الاتحاد واسطوره مثل ايتو
انه يتهجم بهالطريقه الا اكيد انه سمع
كلمه موسيقه لا ممكن اسمع كلام من
الجزائريين امام الجزائريين فجرا يعني
طاقتها كلها انا للاسف الشديد حتى في
تصريحه اللي جاي قال لك تعرضت الى الى
الكثير من الناس تتحدث علي بالاساءه بعد
المباراه انت عندنا متحدث عليه الناس اطلع
بتقرير اطلع من اطلع بالفيديو بره هذا
الشيء مش تفجر عليك
انا شخصيا
طيب بعد الحادث يقال انه همم سودره كاميرا
تقتل ال- ال- ال- الحديث بالكاميرا وثقت
الحديث ومن اول ما وصلتوا حتى ان شاء الله
بحول الله حتى لو طلبت مني السلطات القطري
انا مستعد بهذا الشيء وتشوفوني الحديث كيف
كان اصلا فيديوهاتي كلها انا بضحك ممكن هو
يتوقدني ما يفهم كلامي العربي يتذكر ممكن
انا
شغلتنا نحن نفسنا احنا نقول استفزه وانا
كلي كلامي اضحك حتى لو انا ممكن ضربني
وتشوفني انا اضحك
في الفيديو يعني انا ضحكت تتكلم مع
الفيديو وافكر استهزاء وانا اتكلم باللغه
العربيه انا جماعه معي اتصال اليوم راح
نسال عليها
المشجعين هناك حتى انتظرك وانا احكي معه
قلت لها
كويسين
المباراه الجزائر
[موسيقى]